Infinity stones how do you have these
oh we actually get a lot of those
some of the guys use them as paper weights
Welcomeback everyone this is going to be my new marvel
loki video explaining why the infinity stones
don't work anymore loki's given away infinity
stones like their party favors who wants a new
paperweight for their desk so marvel did just make
the infinity stones useless i'll explain why they
don't work and more about how the timekeepers were
actually able to do that so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos i'm doing videos for all the episodes and
i'm doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
and all my marvel videos all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and let me know
which of those infinity stones you would take if
you could get them to work again but careful for
spoilers from everything that happened in loki
episode 1 if you have not seen the episode yet
during the episode after almost having to
explain what a fish is to casey here like
i will gut you like a fish what's a fish casey is
the name of the desk worker here played by eugene
cordero who was also manning the front desk when
they first brought him in sort of setting up the
big tesseract twist like oh what's this it seems
stupid loki forces him to give the tesseract back
with the idea that he'll just open another portal
and escape judgment it'll make a clean getaway
but then they reveal what else he's got in that
little lost and found style desk drawer and it
shakes loki to his very core he's horrified
like his whole world just crumbles around him
this is really when he's meant to hit rock bottom
not only are there countless priceless artifacts
from the marvel movies and from real life and
just in general there like the honest wagner card
that's worth over 3 million dollars if you're a
big baseball fan they have all six infinity stones
and in most cases duplicates multiple copies of
infinity stones like loki could theoretically
make two infinity gauntlets which normally would
make him the ultimate power in the universe just
double fisting infinity gauntlets but instead he
winds up acknowledging the tva is actually the
greatest power or might be the greatest power in
the universe because they're treating the infinity
stones as if they're completely worthless in
fact the way casey talks about he says oh we
get these all the time but the whole drawer itself
is just meant to show you how little they care for
what you would normally consider to be extremely
valuable in rare items like if you or i found the
hoeness wagoner card sitting in the desk drawer
there we'd just have a heart attack because it's
worth so much money loki has a small heart attack
looking at the treasure chest of infinity stones
so after the episode aired a lot of people saw
this scene and yes it is meant to be kind of
funny because they're playing on the whole fish
scene with casey it's just meant to be a comedic
scene in general but a lot of you on my episode 1
video were commenting wondering if this was marvel
trampling on black widows sacrifice and iron man's
sacrifice in avengers endgame like if marvel is
saying the infinity stones don't matter anymore
what did black widow die for what did iron man die
for so just to clear this up you're at least half
right there marvel is using this scene to make
loki feel very small and insignificant taking the
wind out of his sails and yes they are using it in
a meadow way to say that the infinity stones won't
be a thing anymore in marvel phase 4 movies like
we spent 10 plus years during the infinity saga
movies treating the infinity stones as if they
were the most important thing in existence this
big mcguffin across 22 plus films now kevin feige
and the marvel movies wanna move on to the next
big thing move past the infinity stones and also
say that no marvel villains won't be traveling
back in time again repeating the thanos plot
repeating the avengers plot and just trying to
assemble another infinity gauntlet and just do
the exact same thing over and over again so they
needed some way to logically explain how that was
not possible anymore and sort of wink from behind
the camera and tell fans no we're not going to go
back to these in a big way anytime soon but here's
the big twist with the tva and the timekeepers
the way the tva is able to make it seem like these
infinity stones don't work anymore isn't because
they're more powerful than the infinity stones
the infinity stones themselves haven't changed
fundamentally they're still crazy powerful this is
where we get into a lot of the smoke and mirrors
aspect behind the timekeepers like wizard of
oz style who's really behind the curtain here
what's really going on yes the timekeepers do
have advanced control of time travel and time
manipulation making it seem as if they're powerful
as gods but they're not actual gods not in the way
the one above all in the marvel universe is the
true god or even in the way that thor is a lesser
god in the mcu there was a joke about this earlier
in the episode when loki is on trial asking to
speak to the time keepers gods to gods and judge
renslayer just says they're far too busy to meet
with him but that was kind of a misdirect it was
more foreshadowing for the wizard of oz style
reveal dark twist time keepers are not gods so the
way that the tva is able to make it seem like they
could cancel the infinity stones power or suppress
them is actually because the time keeper citadel
here exists in its own separate pocket dimension
outside the normal flow of time what you would
consider the normal multiverse so when you say
beings like the schuma goreth the many angled
ones were born in the void before the existence
of the universe before the big bang before the
multiverse was created the timekeeper citadel
exists in a space like this outside of what you
would consider the normal multiverse which is how
they're protected from changes in the timeline
that's why nobody in this place got snapped when
thanos assembled the infinity gauntlet in infinity
war that's how it's so easy for them to make
decisions like this like no we'll let half of
all life get snapped and then we won't arrest the
avengers because we want them to go back in time
and bring everyone back and the big thing with
the infinity stones is that they only work inside
the universe where they were created so in this
destroyer you have infinity stones from a bunch
of different universes and that's why they don't
work like loki could theoretically use some of
these infinity stones to make an amalgam infinity
gauntlet travel back into the main marvel universe
where he came from we'll call that the universe
that loki 616 came from even though technically
the mcu is supposed to be a different universe per
marvel phase 1 phase 2 and phase 3 but if he did
that the only infinity stone that would work would
be the tesseract because that's where he stole
this tesseract from all these other infinity
stones came from other universes so they'd be
completely worthless but if it still wasn't clear
why there are so many infinity stones in this
drawer here it's just because the idea you have
all these nexus events being created these branch
timelines the tva goes in arrests whoever created
the nexus event then takes the infinity stone that
they use to do that and throws it in a desk drawer
so you just have a bunch of them accumulating
over time so even though the marvel movies going
forward aren't going to use the infinity stones
the same way ever again as big plot devices
and they're turning them kind of into jokes
here like these are just completely ridiculous
things sitting in a desk drawer the reason why
this scene doesn't completely throw iron man and
black widow's desk under the bus is just because
of the idea that they only work in their original
universes so they're not taking away the power of
the infinity stones they've just shifted them to
another reality where they don't work anymore if
you took all these individual infinity stones back
to where they got them from then they would work
again but i think the idea is that a lot of these
were collected from branch timelines nexus events
that created new branch timelines that they then
close down so you could not take these back to the
universes that they came from anymore because they
don't exist and in case it's been a hot minute
since you've re-watched avengers end game thanos
actually said that he atomized the infinity stones
after he traveled to his garden planet to prevent
anyone from using them again so he didn't fully
destroy them because that's impossible he merely
changed their state to the level of atoms so
they're just imperceptible and ant-man could try
to go around and collect every single atom of the
different stones and reconstitute them that way
but it would take a billion years to do that but
per the rules that the ancient one explained to
the hulk that's how the normal flow of time in the
main marvel universe continues on going forward
like it's supposed to for all the regular avengers
characters the infinity stones are supposed to
help control the flow of time and at the end of
the movie captain america returns all the ones
that they stole back to where they came from
eliminating those other potential nexus events
they created along the way like he says i'll clip
all the branches bruce talking to the hulk also
for those of you asking about why old man captain
america did not get arrested because he went back
to live with peggy carter in 1942 creating another
separate branch timeline in another nexus
event the reason why the tva probably didn't
arrest him is probably for the same reason judge
renslayer claims that the avengers all were not
arrested probably because the timekeepers claimed
captain america was supposed to do what he did
supposed to travel back in time to be with peggy
carter and then come back to the main timeline
and if that seems kind of suspect like why would
they want him to do that and break the rules in
that way and not arrest him but not want loki to
do what he just did at the beginning of episode
one it just plays into the idea that something is
wrong with the timekeeper something is sinister
it's supposed to feel like they're not really good
characters also for those of you asking about the
peggy carter cameo scene that a lot of people were
discussing on social media no i do not think that
this person in the background of the scene is
supposed to be peggy carter there is a woman
being arrested by the tva in the background when
loki is trying to escape who's dressed in a blue
outfit with a haircut that seems similar to peggy
carter it's not the same outfit that peggy carter
was wearing like this is a completely different
outfit but just because she looks kind of similar
and she's kind of blurry and you can't see her
face really people wondered if it was peggy carter
i think this is just meant to be a random person
in the background continuing to illustrate the
tva arrests all kinds of people from different
eras all over the place all the time like the
douchebag from goldman sachs getting vaporized
i think if this were supposed to be peggy carter
the creators of the tv show the cast and hayley
atwell herself would be talking about it by now
the best example of something like this is mark
hamill's cameo scene on the mandalorian season 2
the minute the mandalorian season 2 finale
was released mark hamill started tweeting
all kinds of funny references to his cameo scene
without completely giving away spoilers like have
you seen anything good today anybody watching any
good tv episodes so had this have actually been
peggy carter you would have seen a bunch
of official marvel people talking about it
and even though they did get a little
confusing with the way they talk about
the one single sacred timeline concept there is
still a multiverse like they've sort of wound
the what they consider to be the sacred multiverse
into a single timeline the sacred timeline
it's just that the timekeepers have the tva
hunters eliminate branch timelines that they deem
bad so there are other realities as part of this
single sacred timeline all kind of wound together
in a single timeline but they'll continue
to explore this and explain how this works
in episode 2 in future episodes so if it feels
like it's still kind of confusing now don't worry
they'll continue to explain stuff through future
episodes there are also a lot of you asking about
dr strange's 14 million possibilities when he was
using the time stone during infinity war the whole
idea being that he found the one timeline where
they were able to beat thanos and that involved
their time travel plot so the funny thing that
judge renslayer is talking about here like the
avengers were supposed to go back in time that's
why they weren't arrested the idea is is that the
avengers had actually done something different
tried some different plan in those 14 million
they would have created another nexus event
creating another branch timeline that the
timekeepers did not want to exist in the tva would
then have stepped in to shut it down so like i
said tom hiddleston did confirm the series would
continue to explore the whole wizard of oz aspect
of this like the darker implications of this idea
that the time keepers deem what is sacred and
what is not sacred who's really behind the curtain
who's really pulling the strings here because they
definitely do not seem like good people and just
because they are moving past the infinity stones
as big plot devices in marvel phase four doesn't
mean that they won't ever reference them again so
for instance we have the eternals movie coming
up later this year and yet the idea that the
celestials in the early history of the mcu would
go around the universe gardening things growing
experimenting on things creating the eternals
creating the deviants and when they were doing
that they would use infinity stones to aid them
in their tasks like you have issan the searcher
using the power stone to cleanse this planet that
he deemed the experiment it failed on okay time to
start over again we'll just wipe the slate clean
and try over so we'll probably see some references
to the infinity stones again during the eternals
movie when they're explaining the backstory the
creation of the celestials and the creation of
the eternals just an example of how even though
they're not going to be a really big deal going
forward the infinity stones themselves are still a
big deal technically one of the very few replicas
that i allowed myself to buy was a full-size
replica of the infinity gauntlet after infinity
war came out although it took so long for them
to make that that i actually didn't receive it
until after avengers end game came out in theaters
my full loki episode 2 video is going to
post wednesday just like normal there's a
special new spider-man teaser that was released
sometime recently i might do a video for that
tomorrow make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss any of the episodes
and congratulations just some guy with a mustache
you're the giveaway winner from my last big marvel
video please email me on the about page of
my channel so i can get your contact details
everyone click here for my full loki episode
1 video and click here for my loki episode
2 trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!